une image très forte à laquelle on a
assisté hier depuis de nombreuses
semaines maintenant olive et veyran le
ministre de la santé fait tout pour
accélérer la vaccination et l'ancien
neurologue a même enfiler la blouse
blanche et à lui-même vacciné quelques
patients pour fighter coûte comme réussi
ou pas osé nous dit on regarde c'est
d'avoir en effet le ministre de la santé
a renfilé sa blouse blanche de médecins
comme il l'avait promis aux différents
si un neurologue à participer à l'effort
de vaccination en région parisienne sous
l'oeil des caméras et des photographes
il a par ailleurs demandé aux français
d'adapter leurs vaccinations planning de
vacances et non l inverse
pour éviter les engorgements cet été
ouais désengorgement coup de kobe
oui je le verrais très réussie c'est
bien le voilà sur le terrain c'est comme
quand blanc caire va sur le terrain moi
j'aime ça il donne l'exemple il est la
dose et les bravo à lui vous êtes devenu
un sujet dix minutes j'étais contre le
gouvernement donc oui mais vous avez
changé
c'est un coup de com mais pas réussi je
sais pas si c'est ce qu'on attend du
ministre de la santé en son nom à ce que
son rôle c est se déguiser et d'aller
avec 6 mais bon c'est très s'est déguisé
ici semble
la séquence de minutes c'est ça ou de
gérer le déconfinement le retour à la
vie normale des jaloux parce qu'en fait
il a été tellement très beau quand il
s'est fait vacciner et les femmes ont
été très touchés par l'âge
je tiens à être touché par tous les
particuliers qui sont quasiment non mais
j'ai remarqué que toute la gente
masculine était devenu anti véran depuis
ce premier axe en bon état mais parce
que vous êtes à la hauteur mais
peut-être que oui il est comme un élève
développé-couché 125 125 mais ça n'est
pas la beauté des franchement laurence a
encore une mise en scène lui l'un des
gens attendent autre chose du ministre
il est en train de se mettre en selle
vous allez jouer à la marelle j'en
attendais il faut arrêter après de se
plaindre que les téléspectateurs où les
gens commencent à douter de leur
politique
je trouve la mise en scène vraiment nul
naze et c'est vraiment pas long c'est
démago alors oui non mais moi je vois ça
comme un acte symbolique pour inciter
les gens à se faire vacciner pour aider
les aides soignants donc non je trouve
pas du tout que c'est une mise en scène
au contraire ses besoins alors et on
voit si un sondage ou alors c'est
toujours des sondages c'est un bonus ion
oui bonne idée car la bourse ont une
mauvaise idée 57% et oui